when we think of the ocean we think of
the beach but i'm speaking to one of a
handful of people who have been to the
deepest depths of our oceans
my name is bruce strickrot and i am
currently the senior pilot and manager
of alvin operations group at the woods
hole oceanographic institution phew he
pilots a submarine called alvin and he
works with scientists to explore deep
ocean life and terrain you know our
average depth on on most of dives is
between 2500 and 3000 meters that's
almost two vertical miles
this is what it feels like to go ten
thousand feet below the water surface
we dive off and down near the equator so
it's bright and sunny and it's early
morning it's nice
you'll dive in the water and you hit a
color of turquoise that i have never
been able to see anywhere else but that
blue doesn't last long it's easy to lose
light within
five to ten minutes easy and you're left
suspended in seemingly black water
the sub spins the whole way down the
whole way up but you don't even notice
the only only way you can tell is you
can look at the compass and see us
turning around
within that darkness small flashes
emerge these are from animals who live
at these extreme depths
you hit lots of bioluminescence
the amount that you can see outside is
astounding and then you hit the bottom
when you get to the site that you're
headed to and you turn the lights on
there's a huge wow factor there
in particular areas with geothermal
vents or these underwater geysers
massive structures that rise thousands
of feet up towards the surface
the view out the front is astounding
because there's nothing like it anywhere
else on the planet nothing our
perspective is altered by our experience
because you can't go and look at the
ocean anymore and think of it just as
this endless flat surface of water you
have an understanding of what's
underneath
you